so if you have hypothyroidism i highly
recommend that you take
cod liver oil let's talk about why there
are three
main key nutrients that the thyroid
needs
number one it needs iodine and iodine
makes up
the thyroid molecule itself in fact when
we talk about
t4 or t3 we're talking about the number
of iodine molecules
okay then you have selenium selenium is
involved in an enzyme
that allows the conversion from t4
to t3 the active form of the thyroid
hormone
so you need selenium it's a trace
mineral so about
80 percent of this conversion happens in
the liver and 20
happens in the kidney so you need a
healthy liver
and you need a healthy kidney but
vitamin a is involved in this other
hormone called
thyroid stimulating hormone which is
created from the pituitary
and it's sent down to the thyroid so it
tells the thyroid what to do
and this whole chain of events is on a
negative feedback loop in fact the way
they diagnose
hypothyroidism is with the thyroid
stimulating
hormone if the thyroid stimulated
hormone goes
up because there's no negative feedback
coming back that's one way they would
diagnose
a hypothyroid case and when you have a
vitamin a
deficiency you have a massive increase
in thyroid stimulating hormone
and that can even increase the size of
the thyroid as in a goiter
and actually decrease the absorption of
iodine so vitamin a is
very important in thyroid function so we
have iodine
selenium and vitamin a now what is the
best source of vitamin a
you might say carrots or spinach well
that will give you the precursor the
beta carotene which is
good but the amount of conversion that's
going to happen is very very tiny
okay because we want the active form of
vitamin a which is retinol
but it is also good for the eyes and the
sinus and many other things
but the thyroid is another
benefit from vitamin a now you can get a
lot of vitamin a from liver
in fact you might get too much if you
have too much liver so you'd have to
have just a small amount of liver
that's probably one of the best sources
of vitamin a if you like liver and you
don't overdo it
i'm going to recommend cod liver oil
because a regular
recommended amount if you're going to
get a supplement would give you about
150 percent of vitamin a which is
a little more than what your body might
need not too much
just enough and plus cod liver oil will
give you vitamin d
it will also give you omega-3 fatty
acids
you can also find retinol in butter
grass-fed butter
eggs fatty fish cheese
and other foods as well but i wanted to
emphasize the importance of vitamin a
for the thyroid all right thanks for
watching
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will
show you how to bulletproof yourself and
so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today